[Music]
the tigray region in northern ethiopia
is known for its assembly of raccoon
churches
[Music]
sculpted out of sandstone the most
wondrous of these is abuna yamataga
[Music]
there's only one way up
you have to climb this cliff face
welcome to the world's most perilous
church
[Music]
established in the 5th century the
church is named after its founder and
builder father yamada
[Music]
perched 650 feet above a steep cliff
some say he chose its location to be
closer to heavenly spirits others argue
it was a strategic move to avoid his
enemies
either way the church's location sealing
frescoes and precious goat skin bible
have attracted worshipers for centuries
[Music]
the church has 20 clergy men and is
managed by this high-ranking priest
he has lived here for over 47 years and
he makes the climb every day
[Music]
[Music]
for fearless worshipers the two hour
trek to the top begins by hiking to the
bottom of the rock from the valley below
visitors must first remove their shoes
before climbing
[Music]
muslim in the
[Music]
is
the final obstacle to the church's
entrance contests the most ardent
pilgrims faith
a narrow cliff ledge with a deadly drop
to the left and no room for error
[Music]
once through you may think you're in
heaven
but you've never felt more alive
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you